hey guys I'm Dave Rubin and this is the
all-new Reuben report I don't see any
appendages that aren't supposed to be
there well you can't see alright I'm
here with lemon now that you've been
trigger warned yeah let's talk about
free speech 30 people and a dog fled to
a safe space we're gonna be rounding out
the political and current events
coverage hey guys I'm in the spin room
of the Reagan Library for tonight's GOP
debate I literally think I might have
the only person that asks anyone in that
room about money in politics is Scott
Walker he went out of the race two days
later dude can you think of a politician
off the top of your head that's
consistent actually that really is is
governing or a real setup I can't think
anyone we're going to talk about big
ideas here bad ideas are worse than bad
people cuz bad ideas are contagious bad
ideas get good people to do horrible
things
stop your fingers and somebody agrees
with you I will consistently stand for
liberal values and I won't demonize
everyone who disagrees with me you are a
gay conservative I think it's weird
conservative people why would that be
strange we should debate everything we
should talk about everything we should
engage in ideas that we aren't
comfortable and I've had my own
awakening that I realized it was my guys
it's my guys on the Left that are trying
to silence people like you and so what
would you say to the people that would
argue well we really created Isis well
can go to hell without America lifting a
finger let's keep pushing the
conversation forward so we can build
bridges where others would just tear
them down